ihre partei hat bei den wahlen das
wählerreservoir der anderen parteien
wenn nicht kannibalisiert doch so
ziemlich angenagt jetzt fliegen von
allen politischen seiten die herzen zu
von rechts und von links aber die gefahr
besteht dass sie irgendwann mal zu viele
interessen bedienen müssen dass sie zu
viele gegensätzliche wünsche erfüllen
müssen ja gut also wir haben eine
attraktivität tatsächlich in alle
politischen etablierten politischen
lager hinein
das kommt dadurch im augenblick sehr
zupass weil wir davon profitieren in
form von großartigen wahlerfolgen es
gibt ja auch tatsächlich schnittmengen
mit den verschiedenen politischen lagern
natürlich gibt es schnittmengen mit der
cdu gerade in thüringen also auf was im
bildungspolitischen bereich
beispielsweise angeht oder den
familienpolitischen bereich obwohl wir
da relativ oder wesentlich deutlicher
formulieren als die cdu die sich da doch
mehr dem zeitgeist genähert hat es gibt
aber auch sicherlich überschneidung mit
ansätzen linker programmatik
beispielsweise bei der forderung nach
mehr direkter demokratie
da sind wir bei den linken auch dabei
auf der europaebene natürlich auch die
kritik an der bankenrettung so wie sie
angelegt ist da gibt es auch durchaus
ansätze erwarte aber die frage war ja
dass sie dann irgendwann man nicht zu
viele wünsche erfüllen wenn sie so viele
aus so vielen richtungen wähler bekommen
wie gesagt im augenblick ist eine
luxussituation so einen guten zuspruch
aus allen langen zu haben wir haben ja
immer mal wieder in der vergangenheit
den jüngeren vergangenheit formulierte
afd
er hat das potenzial dazu eine eine neue
volkspartei zu werden grundsätzlich ist
das auch durch meinungsumfragen so
bestätigt worden dass sich gut 20
prozent der menschen vorstellen können
die afg zu wählen als alternative partei
ich glaube die alternative ist deswegen
auch alternativ fall jenseits der der
pragmatischen fragen der politik weil
sie auch den mut hat dinge anzusprechen
die bisher im politischen diskurs eher
stiefmütterlich behandelt wurden oder
von tabus umstellt war nicht immer
beispielsweise mal das thema
einwanderung das auch einer sachlichen
erörterung zugänglich gemacht werden
muss und ich denke das nehmen die
menschen war und deswegen haben auch in
zukunft unsere chance haben gesagt
luxusproblem im moment oder der luxus so
viele stimmen zu haben opposition die
kann ja auch verschleißen
fast noch erste mann der regierung ist
wir haben ja keine regierungsbeteiligung
in aussicht wie wollen sie diesen
problem entgehen
ich denke persönlich das dass wir uns in
opposition ist mir nicht verschleißen
werden sondern bin ich froh dass wir
noch einige zeit haben werden und
inhaltlich weiter zu profilieren und aus
zu schärfen
also in thüringen werden wir jetzt in
kürze auch mit der ausarbeitung zu der
der organisation von landes
fachausschüssen beschäftigen wenn jetzt
erst mal eine fraktion aufbauen wir sind
alles keine berufspolitiker sondern da
muss eben auch verwaltungsarbeit gemacht
werden dass wir relativ schnell leisten
können weil wir alle reichhaltige
berufserfahrung haben aber die arbeit
muss gemacht werden deswegen so habe ich
mich nicht darum jetzt abgeschliffen zu
werden der opposition im gegenteil wir
werden die opposition nutzen um
kommentierte forderungen in die
politische diskussion einzuspeisen
entsprechende klar klare anträge in die
debatten ein zu pflegen und das finde
ich sehr gut tun glaube ich so weit wie
ein höcker im phoenix interview
vielen dank dass sie daran